voici un jeton qui vaut 40 centimes ce
n'est quand même pas bien cher et bien
ce jeune homme ce misérable a trouvé un
moyen de l'utiliser indéfiniment j'ose à
peine vous dire comment figurez-vous
qu'il la tâche à une bobine de fil et
voici comment ce mauvais français fraude
et risque de déséquilibrer à lui seul le
budget des ptt et si je vous montre
aujourd'hui comment ça marche c'est
vraiment pour condamner ces procédés
infâme quelle route quel rôle
il faut d'avoir décroché
introduire ensuite le jeton tout à fait
normalement dans la fente
donner du mou jusqu'à ce que on en tant
que malade
cela tend à l'état fait mon numéro
gerber donc le ministère des ptt
[Musique]
alors n'avais que ça sonne il faut
relever le jeton
moi je le fixe et je vais attendre la
réponse de la standardiste
quelle honte
c'est inqualifiable
vtt bonjour madame je suis en train
d'expérimenter un nouveau type de jetons
pour cabine publique est ce que vous me
recevait bien cinq sur cinq
mais non je vous demande une petite
réponse madame
ah non non mais je voulais simplement
une réponse vous m'entendez bien madame
merci beaucoup
récupéré le jeton
et pour le récupérer
je vais le laisser descendre
là et il va arriver ici dans son petit
logement
y est
c'est bien ce jeton je tombe dont je me
suis servi alors maintenant pas la peine
de couper le fil il suffit de décrocher
la et de récupérer le fils c'est
scandaleux d'avoir imaginé une quelque
chose jamais je ne m'abaisserai à
employer un procédé aussi méprisables
j'espère bien que vous y renoncerait
vous aussi je vous rappelle quand même
que le fils doit être assez long et
assez solide mais c'est vraiment honte
[Musique]